Figaro live bonjour nous sommes en
direct il est midi en direct de nos
studios au Figaro mais aussi et surtout
en direct de Londres vous le voyez c'est
le discours du trône aujourd'hui mais ce
trône est vide c'est une première depuis
1963 on va tout vous expliquer bonjour
Jean descart bonjour merci d'être avec
moi très grand spécialiste de la royauté
évidemment preuve en est ce livre que
vous vous publiez aujourd'hui c'est chez
Perrin pour la reine j'en décarres du
coup on parle là dedans on parle de son
caractère de son tempérament qui
explique tous les événements qu'elle a
vécu Dieu sait s'il y en a eu et ces
réactions c'est une analyse qui je crois
n'avait pas été faite au-delà de tous
les événements que l'on connaît parce
que tout de même 70 ans de règne de quoi
dire il y a de quoi dire et justement on
peut le dire dans ce dans ce livre pour
la reine hommage à Elizabeth 2 je vous
le remontre et on vous le remonter tout
à l'heure parce que c'est vraiment très
très bon alors ces images genre d'écart
expliquez-moi essayons d'expliquer
prenons les choses dans l'ordre la reine
d'Angleterre Elizabeth II ne prononcera
pas le discours du Trône Buckingham
explique je cite la reine continue
d'avoir des problèmes de mobilité
épisodique et après consultation avec
ses médecins a décidé à contrecœur de ne
pas participer au discours du Trône
d'abord Jean qu'est-ce que c'est que le
discours du Trône alors le discours du
Trône c'est le moment le plus symbolique
de l'association entre le gouvernement
et le monarque d'accord c'est donc une
entente très importante
symbolisée par un discours qui écrit le
premier ministre la reine peut faire
quelques remarques souverain un peu dire
tel ou telle chose mais qui doit être lu
par le souverain selon un protocole très
très précis alors l'événement est
d'autant plus important qu'il est rare
une suspension de la présence de la
reine
ne s'est vu que deux fois
c'est la troisième fois la première fois
en
1959 du prince Andrew et la seconde fois
en 1963 était enceinte du passé
historique cette historique alors le
deuxième point je dirais c'est que la
reine qui vient d'avoir 96 ans et je
rappelle quel est le seul chef d'État en
fonction à ce jour qui a vécu et connu
la deuxième guerre mondiale ce qui
suppose des milliards d'épreuves et de
difficultés
c'est très important
que ce soit son fils bien sûr l'héritier
à qui elle a déjà transmis un certain
nombre de fonctions laissez-moi
expliquer que la reine n'est pas là mais
il faut bien quelqu'un prenant la
Couronne représentée et c'est donc son
fils qui sera ici mais qui ne sera pas
sur le trône non il ne sera pas sur le
trône il est l'héritier légitime ça
n'est pas une cérémonie du couronnement
je dirais que on veut éviter c'est
normal de représenter la reine diminuée
ou trop fatiguée on le ferait pour
n'importe quel chef d'État et quand on
ne l'a pas fait on l'a beaucoup regretté
et j'ajoute que depuis quelques semaines
quelques temps le prince de Galles a
communication du contenu des red box ce
sont traditionnellement des boîtes de
cuir rouge au monogramme du souverain
alors qu'on voit l'arrivée pardon je
vous coupe du petit-fils qui sera là lui
pour la première fois le 3e
alors Charles a donc le double des
dépêches d'urgence du gouvernement des
services secrets des services
diplomatiques que la reine avait
commencé à connaître en 1942 lorsque son
père le roi Jean justice a estimé
qu'elle devait être au courant
effectivement ce qui est très important
c'est qu'on voit arriver William c'est à
dire la ligne dynastie la plus complète
à ce jour c'est une première pour lui
oui c'est une première ça prouve que
tout va bien de ce côté-là ça change de
Harry et Megane il faut pas oublier vous
savez que dans les chagrins de la reine
il y a le fait que comme
arrière-grand-mère il y a une petite
arrière petite fille qu'elle ne connaît
toujours pas celle qu'on a stupidement
baptisé Lilly bête Diana aux États-Unis
et qu'il n'est pas né en territoire
britannique la fille
de Mégane et Harry et Harry à qui on a
donné un surnom et non pas un prénom et
le prénom de Diana c'était pas à mon
avis un service à lui rendre alors donc
j'ai l'impression la continuité dynastie
j'ai l'impression je vous coupe Jean
parce que on va suivre évidemment ces
images en direct je pense que dans cette
voiture arrive justement le prince
Charles alors elle a été obligée quand
même pour qu'il puisse prononcer ce
discours de faire une lettre c'est pas
n'importe quoi une autre patente pour
dire je suis mecs ce pouvoir là à mon
fils ce qui était prévu c'est un
protocole très au point depuis longtemps
parce que le souverain peut être empêché
peut être effectivement malade peut être
indisponible mais il faut que ce que
l'ouverture du Parlement soit faite dans
les règles avec le souverain ou le futur
souverain en tout cas la ligne dynastie
officielle alors forcément j'ai des
questions j'en déclare à propos de la
santé de la reine je voudrais qu'on en
parle elle a 96 ans elle fête jubilé de
platine au mois de juin c'est bien ça 70
ans de règne comment va-t-elle
je ne suis pas sur médecin elle a eu je
ne sais combien d'épreuves elle est très
résistante ce qui a certains c'est que
je crois pouvoir dire qu'elle n'a jamais
parce que chez elle le moins abdication
est un chemin qu'elle puisse laisser
le mot abdication c'est un cauchemar
c'est le souvenir de l'abdication de son
oncle Édouard VIII le
duc de Winsor qui a obligé
son père le père d'isabeth à devenir le
Roi George VI qui n'était pas prévu elle
n'était pas princesse héritière au début
et l'année 1936 a été un cauchemar pour
les Britanniques en janvier son
grand-père le grand-père Elizabeth le
roi George V meurt Édouard VIII règne
quelques temps il n'est pas couronné il
abdique parce qu'il veut épouser Wallis
Simpson s'est American 2 fois divorcée
et c'est donc George VI Berti qui monte
sur le trône donc c'est un cauchemar
d'application voilà le père d'Elizabeth
donc en revanche
si sa santé continue à se dégrader
une régence pourrait être instituée
c'est à ce moment-là la Régence serait
assurée par le prince de Galles qui est
prêt pour ça aussi je salue tous ceux
qui nous rejoignent sur YouTube sur Le
Figaro.fr vous réagissez j'en décar vous
répond si vous avez une une question je
lis sigmaster qui dit vive la reine son
pays a un pilier inébranlable justement
je me demandais Jean un soir comme ça
l'info tombe hier soir juste avant le
discours du Trône comment on réagit en
Angleterre est-ce qu'on est inquiet
est-ce que on s'y attend avec l'âge
qu'elle a comment ça se passe parce que
c'est quelque chose qu'on a du mal à
saisir en France et bien il y a les deux
on est inquiet parce que on n'a pas
envie de savoir que cette dame
fantastique dans son genre je veux dire
qui lorsqu'elle est montée sur le trône
Staline était toujours à Moscou donc
c'est quand même une traversée
incroyable c'est possible que je vienne
de voir Harry ou c'est impossible je
n'ai pas alors on va survivre j'ai vu
quelqu'un qui potentiellement lui
ressembler alors ce serait un événement
là
il serait temps que Harry reprenne sa
place si on a donc William vous me
confirmez c'est bien là non je pense pas
que ça arrive j'ai dû j'ai dû confondre
évidemment donc vous me disiez oui on a
un événement comme ça hier soir à
l'information tombe comment réagissent
les Anglais
tout ils savent que ça peut arriver
compte tenu de l'âge de la reine ce qui
ne veulent pas voir c'est sa déchéance
sa diminution physique ou morale ou
intellectuelle c'est ce qu'on évitera
évidemment c'est c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui elle est remplacée par
l'héritier direct Charles qui est prêt à
prendre la relève il a été formé pour ça
Charles
plus de 65 ans mais vous savez devoir 7
était monté sur le trône très alors
lui dans une belle
rolls ou Daimler j'ai pas vu le capot
mais des belles voitures des belles
limousines
la reine a eu tellement d'épreuves elle
a été tellement
mortifiée de ce qui s'est passé avec
Harry et Megane
oui parce que elle déteste l'étalage en
famille en public du LaSalle
les accusations de racisme en fait tout
ce qui est ridicule
elle a été d'une très très grande
gentillesse d'une grande bonté avec tout
le monde elle a aussi été faut pas
oublier de le dire
très bonne avec Diana après son divorce
elle lui a donné tout l'argent qu'elle
voulait lui demander de d'être
raisonnable mais Dana était persuadée
qu'on voulait l'assassiner donc quand
vous avez quelqu'un qui a une idée comme
ça vous ne pouvez pas en sortir non la
reine est fascinante c'est une mémoire
étonnante de d'un autre temps
voilà qui n'était pas princesse
Erika alors quand on dit la reine on
pense notamment en France on dit il y en
a qu'une
Angleterre
et pourtant elle a des
des causes souveraines si je puis dire
la reine Margaret de Danemark qui est
une femme moins remarquable aussi plus
50 ans de règne aussi c'est une
génération qui a connu la guerre qui a
connu les difficultés les restrictions
la reine a gardé de ses de cette époque
difficile des souvenirs elle a vécu
comme le peuple germanique
britannique je dirais l'avait droit à un
œuf le dimanche au petit déjeuner
l'eau du bain était très rare et pas
très chaude c'est le trait de peinture
de la baignoire avait été dessiné par
son père le roi George VI elle était
confinée à Windsor cette forteresse qui
est extraordinaire il faut rappeler au
passage au téléspectateurs et au
lecteurs que le nom de Windsor a été
choisi en 1917 par son grand-père le roi
George V parce que les rois d'Angleterre
étant d'origine allemande il y a eu
léanove ensuite les sax kobogota ça
faisait tout de même un peu désordre en
pleine guerre contre de Guillaume II
contre l'Allemagne d'avoir aussi un nom
allemand surtout au moment où les
Américains allaient venir aider les
Britanniques si vous nous rejoignez nous
sommes en direct pour ce discours du
Trône un discours sans la reine et ça
c'est une c'est une grande première Jean
déclare ma compagne nous avons ces
images qui nous arrivent de Londres
évidemment si vous nous rejoignez on
vous réexplique Jean on a un discours du
Trône très important déjà expliquez-moi
ce que c'est pour ça le discours du
Trône est le programme politique de la
session parlementaire il est écrit par
le Premier ministre ça c'est intéressant
c'est le premier ministre qui décrit qui
écrit un discours politique ou pas
tellement bah il y a de tout il y a de
tout donc c'est à dire que le mine de
rien la reine peut être amenée et là
aujourd'hui le prince ça peut être amené
à prononcer un discours politique oui
absolument je croyais qu'il y avait une
neutralité de la reine
n'interviendra pas du moins publiquement
elle peut faire savoir que telle ou
telle chose pourrait peut-être être
améliorer ou autre comme ces droits
constitutionnels
va nous permettre depuis la reine
Victoria d'où l'audience chaque mardi
sauf urgence avec le Premier ministre
sur les projets gouvernement le droit
d'être informé le droit de ce documenter
le droit d'alerte justement j'ai une
question là-dessus Jean parce que je lis
que elle a été évidemment hospitalisée
au mois d'octobre on n'a pas forcément
toutes les raisons je la semaine
dernière j'apprends qu'elle ne
participera pas au Garden Party de cet
été il y a des interrogations sur sa
présence à tous les événements de son
jubilé au mois de juin prochain pour
pour les 70 ans de son règne mais on me
dit on me dit pas personnellement mais
je lis en tout cas qu'elle continue à
toutes les semaines Boris Johnson c'est
elle qui est encore vraiment aux
commandes ah oui bien sûr elle est au
courant de tout et elle ne sera jusqu'au
bout elle a par les visioconférences et
la copie de tous les dossiers secrets
confidentiels et elle fait parle de
cette observation qui sont est-ce que
vous croyez que c'est le bon moment
est-ce que c'est la bonne direction plus
des dossiers secrets dont on ne va pas
parler je pense elle est forcément au
courant quelle est la situation d'autant
que c'est une femme qui sait ce que
c'est que la guerre elle a vécu le Blitz
à l'ombre elle a vécu les restrictions
c'est une mémoire Elisabeth II
exceptionnel la connu je ne sais combien
de présidents français les Français
aiment beaucoup genre je vous coupe un
instant pour qu'on écoute ensemble ce
qui se passe l'arrivée du prince Charles
au parle
[Musique]
voilà l'arrivée du prince Charles
accompagné alors c'est très important ce
qu'a fait la reine vous savez
Charles et Camilla se sont mariés
à Winsor la reine n'a pas assisté à la
cérémonie civile il y a eu que la
cérémonie à la chapelle-saint-georges
c'était donc l'amour de sa vie qu'il
connaissait depuis longtemps voulu et la
reine je dirais préparer l'avenir en
décidant qu'elle serait à sa disparition
reine consort c'est un statut très
particulier donc en fait la reine a mis
tout en ordre comme l'avait fait
Philippe dans ses dispositions
testamentaires politiques et familiale
et personnelle alors on explique que
voilà le prince vient d'arriver il va
prononcer un discours la reine n'est pas
là genre expliquer nous une fois
il va lire le discours du Trône qui est
le celui qui marque la séance
d'ouverture du Parlement et de chambres
la chambre est lors de la Chambre des
communes qui a été communiquée à la
reine qui a pu poser des questions
[Musique]
interrogés sur tel ou tel point etc mais
il est écrit par le Premier ministre il
est très rare que la reine écrit
elle-même ses discours elle l'a fait par
exemple son discours de Noël le 24
décembre dernier un discours très
émouvant tout à fait sensible qui a
frappé beaucoup de gens surtout des
désastres
auquel on était confrontés donc elle ne
sera pas là aujourd'hui c'est donc son
fils qui prononce ce discours il reste à
sa place habituelle il ne sera pas sur
le trône le sera le trône sera là mais
je répète qu'il a déjà depuis plusieurs
semaines
comme s'il était souverain pour assurer
une transition en douceur le double des
documents confidentiels officiels du
gouvernement les rapports des services
secrets les rapports diplomatifs les
propositions de loi de débat etc ce
qu'on appelle les fameuses red boxes
parce que c'était des boîtes rouges au
monogrammes du souverain qui sont
aujourd'hui évidemment cryptés alors
j'ai une question il ne sera pas sur le
trône c'est parce que c'est protocolaire
ou c'est mine de rien une pardon une
petite manière de montrer que c'est
toujours la reine qui augmente bah
écoutez oui en fait c'est très très
délicat je ne il faudrait un accord
très délicat parce que la situation ne
s'est pas produit dans une période
relativement récente depuis qu'on a des
mémoires je dirais audiovisuel en
revanche il est prêt à tout vous savez
il y a le nom de code
de décès de la reine comme il y avait
celui de Philippe de tous les membres de
la famille royale
il y en a un qui a circulait à un moment
la reine était pas ravie qu'on le fasse
circuler c'est pas très bon goût donc
Charles est de plus en plus impliqué il
y a une chose que les Britanniques et la
famille royale validité c'est qu'on
montre la souveraine trop diminuée
physiquement alors j'ai lu également que
depuis quelques années elle a toujours
participé jusqu'ici on le rappelle c'est
la première fois depuis 1963 parce
qu'elle était enceinte et elle ne
portait plus la couronne trop lourde il
faut dire que vous savez la couronne
elle connaît parce que au moment de de
son couronnement
c'était une telle épreuve qu'elle l'a
portée au petit déjeuner ça faisait rire
le prince Philippe pour s'entraîner pour
pas la perdre parce qu'en plus il y
avait plusieurs changements de couronne
dans la journée parce que j'imagine que
ça doit être lourd et d'équilibre elles
étaient sortis de la Tour de Londres et
alors le avec la couronne au petit
déjeuner c'était quand même curiosité le
prince Philippe s'en amusait beaucoup
voilà les les gardes qu'on appelle les
bifites ce sont des tenues
qui remontent ces gardes là plusieurs
siècles leur expliquera qu'on voit à la
Tour de Londres ce sont ceux aussi qui
gardent des trésors royaux les bifters
c'est une déformation du nom français
buffetier quand il n'y avait pas
l'habitude de la salle à manger mais que
les souverains dans d'autres temps
dressaient des banquets des buffets si
vous voulez alors ce sont des souvent
des soldats émérite très courageux très
médaillés
à cet un événement aujourd'hui c'est on
vit un événement parce que c'est déjà
une transition le fait que le prince
William Salah sa confirme bien la ligne
n'est pas là c'est le prince Charles le
prince héritier le prochain roi qui va
prononcer le discours et donc il était à
chaque fois aux côtés de sa mère
absolument ces dernières années et donc
cette fois c'est donc le petit-fils qui
sera au côté de son père absolument ça
veut dire la lignée dynastie normale je
pense que les Britanniques
qui ont souffert comme tout le monde de
la pandémie qui souffrent de la crise
économique de la sortie avec le brexit
de de beaucoup de choses
se raccroche volontiers à cette image de
stabilité
par laquelle on peut voir que la reine
très consciente de tout à préparer
l'avenir elle a toujours préparé la
ville comme tout le monde et elle ne
veut pas laisser un champ de ruine
derrière alors qu'elle a été très
importante majeur dans l'histoire de la
toujours préparé l'avenir c'est pour ça
que que ses enfants ont appris plusieurs
langues ont eu des échanges
diplomatiques très tôt avec
les grandes familles européennes ou
mondiales
il y a des choses très très drôles
le président Nixon essayait de marier sa
fille au prince de Galles
de loin et Charles a voyagé dans tout le
commonweelf il a été très marqué
lorsqu'il était élève par la découverte
de la Papouasie de la Nouvelle-Guinée de
l'anthropologie il est fasciné par
l'histoire des différentes religions
et pour avoir eu l'honneur de leur
rencontrer c'est un homme absolument
charmant avec beaucoup d'humour alors
j'ai une question genre par rapport à ce
discours du Trône la reine sera absente
on le on le rappelle
expliquez-moi le cérémonial de ce
discours du Trône parce qu'il y a une
robe une cape qu'est-ce que c'est il y a
une tenue particulière on a cette image
qu'on verra alors on va voir ce que ce
que Charles
parce que c'est une une question qui se
qui se pose évidemment pour le protocole
c'est forcément prévu voilà un certain
nombre de garde et de héros d'armes qui
entre
ils sont là on les voit c'est différent
c'est différent je fais un parallèle
c'est différent évidemment mais avec
l'investiture d'Emmanuel Macron samedi
dans toutes les démocraties il y a
vraiment quelque chose de très
symbolique avec les armées les hommes
tous les peuples ont besoin du spectacle
politique c'est alors je vous dirais une
chose c'est que la reine Elizabeth II a
eu une idée géniale et révolutionnaire
en 1953
et bien elle a exigé que son sac est
couronnement soit télévisé ça n'avait
jamais été fait elle ne voulait pas trop
au début
Churchill ne voulait pas Churchill
disait je ne vois pas pourquoi les
caméras de la BBC verrez mieux que moi
donc
il faut bien se replacer dans l'époque
la télévision est au à ses débuts du
ciment
noir et blanc il y a très peu de
téléviseurs mais la Reine a dit je
voudrais que le maximum de la population
puisse avoir l'impression d'être invité
à Westminster même dans les endroits les
plus reculés alors le film a été tourné
d'abord diffuser en noir et blanc le
moment sacré le moment de l'onction
puisqu'elle devient chef de l'Église en
gamme par l'archevêque de Canterbury a
été caché derrière un des on ne l'a pas
vu ensuite
le film a été en même temps tourné en
couleur et le soir même les bobines en
couleur
partait pour l'Australie le Canada la
reine devient avec ça dès 1952 la reine
de l'image elle est restée et je me
souviens
j'ai vu pas très loin d'ici à l'Olympia
j'ai vu ce film qui était un spectacle
et depuis cette date si vous voulez
c'est la monarchie britannique et
devenue le spectacle le plus fascinant
j'en profite pour dire aussi au passage
que par ce spectacle il y a des éléments
très importants qu'on ne voit pas dans
les autres villes aujourd'hui c'est le
nombre de chevaux l'éclair relève de la
garde londres est une ville où le cheval
à sa place d'accord alors en suivant on
verra s'il y a des chevaux mais on est à
l'intérieur vous avez dans cette dans
cet endroit là où je suis passé dans
cette cour alors il y a quand la reine
passer en revue des troupes pour
shopping de coller son anniversaire ou
autre
ce qui était caractéristique comme elle
adore la musique c'est qu'avec son pied
droit elle battait toujours la mesure
d'accord en même temps que la batterie
ça c'est très important la reine fan de
musique bon alors si vous nous rejoignez
il est 12h24 le prince Charles devait
parler à 12h20 bien peu de retard
visiblement il n'y a pas qu'en France
qu'on a du retard la reine d'Angleterre
ne prononcera pas le discours du Trône
c'est une première depuis
1963 elle n'a pas prononcé ce discours
deux fois à un juin 1959-1963 elle était
enceinte c'est deux fois là hier soir
nous apprenons dans un communiqué de
Buckingham la reine continue d'avoir des
problèmes de mobilité épisodique et
après consultation avec ses médecins a
décidé à contrecoeur de ne pas
participer au discours du Trône un petit
point politique peut-être sans aller
trop loin qu'est-ce que ça peut changer
pour Boris Johnson notamment qui a perdu
la semaine dernière de très nombre de
siège dans des élections locales qui est
embourbées dans ce qu'on appelle le
party gate c'est cette soirée à donner
une streak pendant le pendant le
confinement Boris Johnson est-ce que lui
qui a écrit ce discours joue quelque
chose ben écoutez lui oui joue est-ce
que le Parlement va lui tenir les
députés les
membres des communes les membres de
l'Ordre vont lui tenir rigueur de sa
conduite ça je ne sais pas nous allons
voir est-ce que le programme qu'il
annonce suffira
les postes de Premier ministre au
Royaume-Uni j'en profite pour dire qu'on
dit toujours la reine d'Angleterre en
France on a on a tort c'est là c'est la
reine du Royaume-Uni parce que oui parce
qu'il faut pas oublier l'Écosse
l'Irlande du Nord etc le Pays de Galles
est complètement mais si vous voulez on
va voir ce qui est annoncé ce qui est
décidé la reine a eu forcément
communication et possibilité de discuter
du contenu par visio-conférence etc bon
peut-être qu'elle reprend simplement des
forces toutes les hypothèses sont
prévues en voilà une qui est appliquée
évidemment qui inquiète la population
parce qu'on se demande
comment va réellement la reine elle ne
veut pas se montrer
fatigué diminuer on ne veut pas la
montrer diminuer ce serait affreux pour
tout chef d'État ce serait épouvantable
donc voilà peut-être qu'elle va aller
mieux on ne les angles les Anglais et
les autres mais britanniques les
Britanniques exactement est-ce que eux
veulent voir la reine sur le trône
jusqu'au bout ou est-ce qu'il se disent
bon non ils veulent la voir dans le
meilleur état possible y compris les
anciennes colonies
britannique
donc il y en a beaucoup alors il y a les
États du Commonwealth il y en a encore
une quinzaine dont l'arène et la
souveraine il y en a moins que il y a 20
ou 30 ans mais vous savez l'entretenu
des rapports avec tous les pays et dans
les années 60 par exemple contre la vie
du gouvernement parce que c'est une
femme qui a beaucoup de volonté elle est
allée dans un pays d'Afrique le Ghana
l'ancienne gold coach la Côte d'Or qui
était devenue un pays sous influence
marxiste et le gouvernement travailliste
de l'époque n'était pas ravis de voir la
reine partir là-bas mais elle avait
promis à son président Monsieur nekrumma
devenir un problème de calendrier ne
l'avait pas permis c'est une femme qui a
toujours voulu tenir ses promesses elle
y est allée et on a vu cette photo
surréaliste de la reine en Europe du
soir dansant avec ce marxiste en smoking
qui a déclaré qu'elle était la reine la
plus socialiste du monde je salue tous
ceux qui nous rejoignent sur Youtube
Ève notamment Françoise qui ne dit god
save the queen Eve qui nous dit la reine
doit être âgée étagée et doit être
malade rien ne filtre au mois d'octobre
elle est hospitalisée on ne sait pas ce
qui lui est arrivé
problème elle a eu de nom des problèmes
de marche donc elle avait une canne
qu'on a appelé une canne de confort
voilà même les mots sont choisis
oui parce que il y a des moments où elle
n'était pas bien on l'a pas su aussi
c'est quelqu'un de très fort qui ne qui
n'étale pas je dirais ces souffrances à
tout pointu c'est quelqu'un qui est en
cette manière je dirais très bien élevé
très très discrète par exemple
un exemple dans la vie normale si la
reine vous accorde une audience elle
veille à ce que ça ne soit pas brutal
lorsque l'audience est finie elle va
simplement avons changé son sac de bras
et sa date et sa dame d'honneur c'est
que l'audience est finie mais ce sera
dit sans brutalité c'est subtil les
codes plein de finesse pour ne jamais
blesser les gens les vexer alors c'est
propre à la reine d'Angleterre ou ses
propres à tous les souverains non c'est
une école très personnelle de la reine
Elizabeth II et qui était qui déteste
les gens mal élevés attention c'est une
femme qui a un humour fou elle l'a
montré aux Jeux Olympiques de 2012 oui
c'est une mise en scène
pour ceux qui ne s'en souviennent pas
après tellement de gens l'ont interprété
l'ont caricature et des dessins animés
des bandes dessinées etc jouer son
propre rôle même après le film de Queen
qui était formidable avec un film de à
peu près une minute 10
ou elle dira simplement
sont très vexées parce qu'ils n'auront
pas le droit de monter dans
l'hélicoptère les corregistre très
important et elle a fait un tabac si
j'ose dire des devoirs des milliards de
téléspectateurs et les dizaines de
milliers de gens assis dans le Grand
Stade olympique à Londres beaucoup de
d'humour et beaucoup de gentillesse par
exemple si elle reçoit le président de
la République française
pendant le cas de Nicolas Sarkozy dans
la grande plus belle salle du château
Louise de Windsor la salle son nom
officiel c'est la salle Waterloo on peut
pas recevoir un président français dans
une salle Waterloo donc la salle change
de nom
ah donc on est vraiment dans la suite de
délicatesse chez la reine c'est pour ça
qu'elle n'a jamais apprécié je dirais
les les vulgarités les outrances de
Mégane notamment qui en plus rappelle
les audaces invraisemblables de Miss
Simpson pour laquelle son oncle
nous suivons
abdiquer nous suivons en direct et dans
un instant nous verrons les les
premières images du prince du prince
Charles qui doit prononcer un discours
devant la c'est la chambre des lentes
comment on dit OUI
Camilla elle a elle a été très
astucieuse en
disant que sa nouvelle belle-fille le
grand amour de Charles serait reine
consort de façon à ce que tout soit
réglé avance en décès qu'il n'y ait pas
de polémique à ce sujet à tout point de
vue à la préparer l'avenir on suit dans
un instant ces images qui nous arrivent
à progressivement depuis Londres où le
prince Charles va donc prononcer un
discours un discours sans sa mère la
reine d'Angleterre qui le processeur ce
sont des anciennes ce sont des anciennes
images et genre ce que je vous propose
c'est qu'on voit les nouvelles images
les voici en direct depuis cette chambre
rappelez-nous à quoi sert avant
d'écouter progressivement alors qu'on va
Boris Johnson
le système à deux chambres Johnson
Chambre des Lords des pères vous voulez
qu'on a eu sous la monarchie française
et Chambre des députés Chambre des
communes
il y a les va-et-vient etc il y a des
privilèges des des habitudes des droits
enfin bref ce sont des endroits où on a
beaucoup parlé
ou Churchill cette illustré enfin
beaucoup de passer beaucoup de choses
c'est un moment important pour la vie du
Royaume-Uni
alors combien de temps dure ce discours
habituellement c'est quelle est alors là
moi j'en ai vu qui durait quoi de
l'ordre de 20 minutes je ne sais pas
quelle vitesse Charles va le lire il a
il a un grand entraînement il faut
rappeler aussi aux téléspectateurs que
Charles était couronné une fois on
oublie en 1969 il a été couronné par sa
mère prince de Galles au château de
carnaval dans le pays de Galles c'est
obligatoire pour un futur souvain
britannique je lis Eve qui nous demande
en cas de décès c'est William qui prend
le trône non non
toutes toutes vos questions
Gladys qui nous dit la reine du
Royaume-Uni est un arbre pour toutes les
nations voilà alors nous sommes dans
cette chambre et dans un instant donc le
prince William de charge accompagné de
son fils devrait prendre la parole ça
c'est important oui ça veut dire alors
la ligne de succession si vous voulez
est représenter telle qu'elle est prévue
et organisé
organisation très précise de la royauté
on suit attentivement on écoutera par
bride ce que ce que dit le prince
Charles et puis on traduira en vous
expliquera ici les différentes
significations les subtilités de ce
discours écrivez vous me l'avez dit Jean
Descartes par Boris Johnson en personne
alors justement cette question que je me
pose pour ceux qui nous qui nous
rejoignent la reine a en principe un
devoir de neutralité vous me confirmez
alors elle a un devoir de neutralité ne
doit pas exprimer publiquement sur
l'opinion mais il y a des façons j'ai
l'impression que regarder son des images
en direct il n'y a pas de trône à côté
de lui à la couronne mais il est sur
l'autre il est seul
expliquez-moi parce que on se dit il ne
voulait pas sur les accessoires sur le
trône de sa mère allez je vous propose
qu'on l'écoute
voilà pour les premiers mots de du
prince du prince Charles qui pour la
première fois et bien prononce un
discours le discours du trôna la place
de sa mère absente une première partie
où on parle beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat
ça c'est une priorité de Brice Johnson
mais bien sûr la situation économique
est inquiétante pour tous les pays
d'Europe d'ailleurs c'est là où malgré
le brexit bon les problèmes sont les
mêmes les solutions à adapter mais c'est
vrai que le coût de la vie a augmenté
partout et on a les inquiétudes que l'on
a parce que la situation en Ukraine
n'est pas
réglée si je puis dire je vous confirme
donc que le prince Charles ne porte pas
la couronne qu'il n'a pas enfilé la cape
non mais qui lit bien les mots de Boris
Johnson on y revient en l'écoute à
nouveau et puis dans quelques instants à
nouveau on se penche sur sur les mots et
on essaye de traduire d'expliquer la
symbolique de discours
le prince on essaie d'arranger les
choses malgré le brexit c'est ça oui
c'est évident il y a plusieurs
inquiétudes il y a la santé de la reine
évidemment personne nage incontournable
depuis plus de 70 ans dans la vie des
Britanniques et puis il y a la situation
économique les conséquences du du brexit
d'inquiétude avec la situation entre la
Russie et l'Ukraine donc ça fait un gros
si vous voulez tas de problèmes avec
quelque chose qui est affectif c'est de
voir ce qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis 1963
le prince de Galles à la place de sa
mère pour lire le discours du Trône on
s'inquiète elle a 96 ans elle n'est pas
en très bonne santé voilà j'ai une
petite question avant qu'on réécoute ce
qui est en train de nous dire Charles
Flers
lrbt sur Youtube qui nous demande est-ce
que le prince Charles est le plus vieil
héritier de l'histoire britannique
est-ce qu'on a déjà eu un prince aussi
vieux non parce que Edward 7 montée sur
le trône très très
âgé quand il venait en France les
chanceliers alors Monseigneur cette
maman toujours en bonne santé il
s'agissait de la reine Victoria non
voilà
c'est mais ce qu'il y a de certains
c'est que la reine je répète devenu la
reine de l'image
amplifiée par le feuilleton de Crown qui
prend quatre fois des libertés avec la
vérité
libéralisme de la reine et de la famille
royale d'autoriser un tournage de films
où on s'arrête à peine à la chambre à
coucher pour raconter la vie de la
première famille du pays
il y a cette proximité qu'Elisabeth II a
voulu dès 1953 en imposant la télévision
à Westminster ce qui était quelque chose
de d'incroyable et de révolutionnaire et
donc aujourd'hui en 2022 ce discours du
Trône et prononcé à la télévision en
écoute à nouveau un petit peu le prince
Charles
il prononce un discours évidemment très
axé sur la politique anglaise mais ce
qui m'étonne toujours c'est il a un
devoir de neutralité normalement un
discours politique on essaye de le
vendre de de loyer de mettre de la
farine là c'est pas du tout le cas assis
je lis point non mais c'est le système
britannique qui veut ça vous savez vous
avez un exemple elle la reine le
souverain britannique ne doit pas
formuler d'opinion sur son premier
ministre ou d'ancien Premier ministre
bon
Madame Thatcher avec laquelle la reine a
eu du mal à s'entendre parce que Madame
Thatcher se prenait pour l'étal n'était
que le gouvernement
a dû reconnaître Madame Thatcher que la
reine connaissait parfaitement ses
dossiers il y a une exception à propos
de Churchill qui Elizabeth II à la mort
de celui qui fut son premier ministre
vous avez une relation particulière
alors
c'est très bien entendu avec lui parce
qu'il a été le lion que l'on connaît
pendant la guerre elle l'a trouvé
souvent injuste avec le roi Georges VI
un peu un peu trop dur mais elle a eu un
mot formidable au moment où elle a exigé
des funérailles nationales pour un
premier ministre pour Churchill elle a
dit ce mot il était divertissant on peut
pas mieux définir qui était divertissant
l'homme qui disait il faut toujours
boire du champagne si ça va mal on en a
besoin si ça va bien ça fait du bien
voilà
et le bon mot voilà ce discours qui est
terminé je vous propose qu'on écoute un
petit peu l'ambiance sur place à Londres
et puis on revient dans un instant
voilà on présente la couronne mais il ne
la porte pas évidemment ah bah non
peut-être un jour bientôt j'imagine
est-ce que lui on sait si il est frustré
bon j'imagine c'est ça évidemment mais
non non il est prêt vous savez depuis le
temps
il est prêt PAS d'applaudissements je
note ça aussi c'est la sobriété anglaise
ah oui non mais non le moment est quand
même
intense et
c'est une déjà une transition donc c'est
pas un discours à la Chambre des
communes c'est une cérémonie où on pense
à la reine
souffrante qu'on ne veut pas voir
diminué qu'on ne veut pas voir affaibli
ça correspond à son caractère on ne
montre pas
sa douleur son chagrin quand elle a
appris l'assassinat de Lormand battle
parlera elle
dirigé vers le fond du jardin où elle se
trouvait elle s'est tournée pour pas
qu'on la voit de face et on a vu qu'elle
avait des spasmes de larmes voilà
la seule larme qu'on ait vu sur le
visage de la reine de face c'est à la
fin de l'année 97 lorsqu'il y a eu le
désarmement de son yacht royal le
Britannia alors ça paraît bizarre mais
c'était la seule maison qu'elle est
Philippe avait construit et aménagé à
leur c'est un bateau que je connais bien
je l'ai fait visiter dans le port
d'Édimbourg Jean descart j'ai une
remarque là sur le Figaro.fr le roux tu
es où quel gâchis d'argent apparade et
en spectacle c'est vrai qu'on ne
comprend pas forcément très bien ça en
France vous savez il faut dire aux gens
que la monarchie britannique coûte moins
cher que la République française par
citoyen ah oui absolument tous les
calculs ont été faits et que c'est un
spectacle la monarchie oreille plus ou
moins comment dirais-je fastueux ou
autre mais si vous voulez la relève de
la garde est aussi un spectacle n'a pas
la même ampleur c'est pas la même
histoire ce n'est pas le même pays
voilà mais on aime un peu les traditions
partout et non ce n'est pas du gâchis le
peuple a besoin aussi de voir
ce comment sont les gens qui le
représentent etc alors ils sont très
durs avec les scandales avec les gens
qui se tiennent mal on le sait et il y
en a eu
mais là c'est un moment surtout très
intense parce que bon les deux
précédentes fois où la reine n'a pas
présidé la cérémonie n'a pas prononcé
des discours du Trône c'était pour une
bonne raison elle était enceinte et elle
allait
là c'est la première fois depuis 1963
qu'elle est absente pour raison de santé
et d'âge nous venons de suivre donc avec
Jean descart ce discours ce discours du
Trône se serait discours du Trône qui a
lieu tous les ans et pour la première
fois vous venez de l'entendre depuis
1963 pas de reine d'Angleterre c'est
donc son fils le prince héritier le
prince Charles qui la prononcé en
présence de sa femme en présence de son
fils je lis là dans le chat sur Youtube
Jean toujours des réactions de Françoise
de Carla une pensée pour Diana princesse
Diana la meilleure elle est toujours là
dès qu'on parle de la royauté
Diana a occupé le
paysage c'était son plaisir c'était sa
fonction je dirais elle voulait faire
régner l'image je pense que
malheureusement ça a été la cause et
l'origine de bien de ces tourments voilà
ce qu'on pouvait dire sur sur cette ce
discours du Trône je montre quand même
votre votre livre genre évidemment là il
sort aujourd'hui vous le voyez il est
ici pour la reine hommage à Elisabeth II
c'est chez Perrin de quoi vous nous
parlez Jean
va chercher alors allez-y dans toute
dans toutes les bonnes librairies
aujourd'hui exactement voilà moderne et
meuble Elisabeth II est une icône
mondiale on l'a vu aujourd'hui encore
avec ses remous ces remous et cette
absence dans ce pour ce discours du
Trône la première fois depuis
1963 merci Jean d'écart de m'avoir
accompagné c'est toujours un plaisir
d'être avec nous merci à vous la bible
de la royauté Jean merci d'être avec
nous on se retrouve vite sur sur
figarolive avec encore plein plein
d'événements la suite c'est et bien vous
pouvez suivre tout à l'heure à 16h
Emmanuel Macron qui présidera une
cérémonie d'hommage suite à la fin de
l'esclavage évidemment une cérémonie
d'hommage aujourd'hui et puis ce soir
point de vue c'est sur fear live
évidemment merci beaucoup merci de nous
avoir suivi à très bientôt encore merci
Jean allez regardez je remonte une
dernière fois votre livre il est ici
pour la reine de Jean Descartes
excellente journée au revoir